there might be a 14-year gap between the
Incredibles and its sequel but that
didn't stop fans from crowding the
theaters on June 5th 2018 The
Incredibles 2 was everything we'd
expected and more
we loved how violets - and Jack joined
forces to save the day but surprisingly
many scenes didn't make the final cut
watch until the end to find out which
deleted scene could have led to a very
different ending god yes selfie time
here's something we never thought we'd
see - and violet taking selfies together
this deleted scene starts off with -
flashing a camera into violets face
despite her cries of protest the
siblings start fighting and soon the
entire Parr family has come into the
shots Kellan snatches the camera out of
Dash's hand and creates a self-made
selfie stick with her rubbery arms this
scene is absolutely hilarious however
it's easy to see why it got cut from the
movie it's way too futuristic after all
Incredibles 2 is set to take place in
the late 60s which is a selfie stick
free era look at how annoyed violet
looks
she's definitely experiencing
adolescence Edna gives a house tour this
deleted scene is super funny and it
showcases one of our favorite characters
Edna mode is giving Helen and Bob a tour
on her house she's briefing them on
their newest security system and by the
looks of it they're going to need it
after all Jack Jack's powers are out of
control she points out that the system
can detect if people are sneaking in and
sneaking out right then and there
Edna stops violets from sneaking out of
the house proving that the system works
she also points out there's a built-in
fire extinguishing program and she does
this in the nick of time because Jack
Jack soon bursts into flames discussing
supper plans who doesn't like a good ol
punter - well apparently director Brad
Bird isn't a fan because he cut a really
punting scene out of the film
in this deleted scene we see mr.
incredible and Elastigirl taking on a
monstrous drill despite the hectic
scenario Helen asks Bob if he can
prepare dinner tonight and he tells her
he can't because he's got his hands full
this is pretty obvious considering he's
trying to stop a huge drill from tearing
up the city Bob goes on to ask if Helen
can do it instead
and the scene flashes to Elastigirl
stretching her body to prevent a train
from colliding with a sidewalk the scene
ends with Elastigirl telling her husband
that she can't because she's a little
tied up right now
violet gets her payback this deleted
scene didn't make the cuts but that's
only because the movie had to be
shortened to make room for more crucial
scenes we see the par children eating
breakfast while their parents chat in
the background - uses his powers to
quickly steal violets milk when she goes
to reach for it - is laughing at his
prank but he stops giggling when violet
puts a force field around her milk
bottle at this point
jack-jack starts laughing at - proving
that he'll be taking his sister's side
more often than not jack Jack's mess
raising kids is not an easy job so it's
safe to say that doing it on your own is
even harder we see Bob struggle to take
care of his children throughout
Incredibles - but what was once a
mediocre job turns into a challenge when
Jack Jack starts experiencing powers in
this scene we see Bob cleaning up after
a very messy Jack Jack and just when he
thinks that the job is done
Jack Jack surprises him with his laser
beam vision if this was supposed to be
Jack Jack's big power revealed were
happiest cut after all we much prefer
the scene where Bob stumbles upon his
baby fighting a raccoon
Edna babysits Jack Jack Edna Mon doesn't
normally agree to babysit however she
fell for Jack Jack's charm when he
showed her his powerful abilities fans
were upset that they didn't get to see
the events that transpired between the
fashion designer and the car baby but
luckily there's a deleted scene for that
although it may have been cut from the
movie it's still super adorable and
entertaining in this scene we see Jack
Jack exploding with numerous powers in
fact he turns into static energy at some
point and causes the power outage in
Edna's mansion honey
almost made the cut fans have long since
given up hope when it comes to seeing
honey flash across the screen frozen's
wife remains a mystery which only adds
to her character's great appeal believe
it or not but Brad Bird almost agreed to
putting an end to the decade-long
mystery honey was supposed to appear in
the sequels opening scene frozen's wife
would have come off
as a normal civilian at first that is
until she revealed her identity by
pulling Frozone suit out of the closet
Brad wanted fans to be surprised by her
appearance however the director chose
against opening Pandora's box runaway
train parenting roles were reversed in
Incredibles - placing Elastigirl on the
front lines while mr. incredible took on
the role of the stay-at-home dad seeing
the last two girls stop the runaway
train was definitely an action-packed
moment which is why we couldn't imagine
the movie without it coincidentally the
train scene was never supposed to be a
focal point of the movie the director
wanted to keep things short by making
Elastigirl save the Train by simply
pulling on the brake lever luckily they
chose against the simple scene and made
it one to remember without it we
wouldn't have seen just how incredible
Elastigirl really is Helen made Skelly
nobility on a motorcycle look easy the
timeline although this technically isn't
a deleted scene it's an alteration that
could have changed everything we know
about Incredibles - originally Brad Bird
wanted to make the sequel
age-appropriate
meaning that 14 years would have also
gone by for our favorite heroes can you
imagine seeing a teenage dad Jack a
grown up - and an adult violet because
we sure can't thankfully producers chose
not to go in that direction and left the
aging process behind altogether this way
they could really capitalize on Jack
Jack's power reveal and the family's
stellar dynamic would you have liked to
see the Parrs all grown up let us know
which version you would have preferred
in the comments section below the
original screen flavor although it might
be hard to believe Avel endeavor wasn't
originally supposed to play a villain in
the sequel instead Brad wanted Winston
to be the evil genius behind screensaver
in fact the director said that he must
have scrapped two movies worth of scenes
before deciding to make Evelyn the
movies Big Bad Evelyn kept a low profile
throughout the film so it was much more
shocking to find out that she was behind
the villainous screensaver the movie
would have taken an entirely different
direction if Winston hadn't been pegged
as a happy-go-lucky character so which
one of these deleted scenes was your
favorite sound off in the comments
section give this video a big thumbs up
if you love The Incredibles as much as
we do don't forget to hit that subscribe
button for more videos like this one to
come your way
thanks for watching and see you next
time on the things
[Music]